somebody asked me if we ever prepare
like a bullet point sheet who asks you
there our podcast I said no you take you
I said we don't you take that warm old
hand in slam across the face yeah don't
call it did so the person the person
asks you do they want to get in
podcasting yes I have people call me all
the time and say I want to do a pod
connote I say about what you know just
like talking about stuff oh okay do it
God just do it go ahead go and do it
um just do it just do it just do it some
days you wake up and just think the Lord
that you're not Matt Lauer some days you
wake up and you're not sure so I I doozy
surprise they write the Vince friends
are all this and I hate how we always
kind of sexual assaults we harp on it
too much but every morning you know I
watch Bubble Guppies with my son but
when he if he's on focus or he's busy
something else
Oh Papa likes to watch first take
usually sure but if the Today Show's on
I'll check out that for some current
events maybe you know trying to get my
worldly news going that or CNN yeah I
checked on there I see him my boy man I
was not on there yeah people are I'm
gone people being now at our time
yeah Matt Lowrey coming his office you
better think of an escape plan and quick
except for how to lock at at his desk he
had a lock ah I think what this is gonna
do is basically I think that if you're a
woman in the workplace after a while you
probably not gonna have to worry about
everyone's probably at the end of the
day a good thing right
cuz you don't want to have to deal I
think people are gonna I feel like guys
are gonna live a little bit in fear like
like right we just saw that pretty girl
impasse in the bathroom yeah
not that I got any ways pretty even I
was like oh man I don't you know I would
never say anything never right hey I've
never said anything when the girls
walked by my life yeah yeah whoo that's
never what we're aware of your impact
hey construction workers and ever works
when the girl walks by now never when
you whistle at them doesn't work anyway
cat calls don't work so but I've never
done that but it you know if it's a
great car goes by you look if a
beautiful girl you'd like jeez you know
she
yawn the eyes yeah I won't even well so
so here's what I've been thinking about
this I think that I never ever had to
think about my impact I think I consider
myself a good guy you're a good guy
but I never thought of my impact like I
never thought about how this this guy
did this really interesting thing where
he has he makes these these what is it
called appearances like these speeches
and he says all right so I have a board
here I all the men what what steps do
you take every day to avoid being
sexually assaulted or raped or you know
and of course nobody raised their hands
guys like [ __ ] off I don't think about
them then he has the women to it
I dried taken account Howard dress I
carry my keys in my thing I carry pepper
spray when they're girls a lot like
literally the whole board fills up when
you look at it from that perspective
where women kind of look at the world is
way more dangerous because they're just
smaller and more vulnerable at least is
a guy who's not that sensitive like me I
mean having a daughter you should that
should been your first thought is that
no because you get more protective so I
said you're good you go but like I don't
need to go hits it on the guy's speech
to realize women go through that sure
but but then at least you'll be a little
bit more aware like I think guys are
never really taught to be even really
cognizant of that not as much I think
more now now guys will be a little bit
more or maybe it's just [ __ ]
I think he's just [ __ ] I was always
very guys aren't aware of their it makes
me like I've been around where guys have
got like grabbed a girl been super
physical or touchy-feely and you can
tell she's not into it I'm on come from
like good god bro well that's that year
I like it like I wonder even when
they're hitting on a girl she's not into
it I'm on Cup yeah or they cat call a
girl or but I I saw a guy one time who
was drunk he's my neighbor and I watched
him get drunk
and he was a was he's like a lawyer he's
like a rich guy and cuz he rented the
the large apartment on the beach next to
me I had a small apartment in Venice
this is a long time ago man I watched
that dude get drunk and I watched him
become basically a banking rapist oh
yeah I'm not kidding he looked so nasty
and he was like come over here hey come
over here this girl and this other girl
goes that guy tried to grab me and
let me out of the corner he's a Croesus
and I was like and I looked at him and
he had a mean expression he's dangerous
but that guy get away with it he would
rape women he probably does that's a
whole different [ __ ] the good thing for
guys like chin coming on in mr. nice guy
not a threat
- nice yeah - nice but that nice but
that's what they're looking for now no I
don't think so
well you'd be surprised the problem is
that women want you to be really like at
heart but I think they want a little bit
of that yeah Fifty Shades of Grey
see you 50 shades of chin come on in
just smile and that is the that is the
weird thing is that like a lot of times
women will tell you they like a man in
control aggressive and all that but at
the same time that might be so but it
doesn't mean you want to be [ __ ]
harassed when you're trying to work you
know I mean it doesn't mean you want to
come to work and be forced into a
situation where you can't stand it
because the guy might fire you so you
have we have we made any progress here
in daily life we've we've kind of backed
off look who's with feller we're
pressuring to get your dick out hmm no
progress simple as that just not a
priority for you that's what we realize
you know if we can't want you to want a
girlfriend yeah so we backed off but
well I think there's one killer breath
besides the point that - but if I meet
someone if it's cool she's awesome
yeah but not a priority Brian doesn't
care no no no we just don't think yeah
you'll find somebody
thank backed off because we don't want
oppression I appreciate that guy yeah I
hope you guys you know I hope you do
find that true love I hope both you guys
kind of enjoy most things like you need
a Matt Lauer chin like you need to but
female like you're walking off she lost
you and there just has a way sometimes
if you find that a female is like you're
lacking she's lacking something you may
want to take a look at what you really
need which is maybe she needs a [ __ ]
that says maybe it's time you make the
old switches switcheroo sexuality is a
very complicated thing rife with a
danger rife with choice what can you do
for the change
I'll tell you who was a real sexy and I
started watching a show Aquarius on
Netflix it's a it's the detective I'm
based loosely off trout the transmat
stuff but it's all about Charles Manson
detective trying to find him the guy
from x-files is in it I haven't seen him
David Duchovny I worked with him oh yeah
I haven't seen him in forever anyways
it's just the Charles Manson history and
going everything dude I didn't realize
how I mean it was to paying you canyon
venice right by my uncle's house Charles
Mann stayed just four blocks from there
killed people half a mile from where I
live really yeah I went last night
couldn't sleep for anymore so I went
through a maps they have this thing you
look for Charles Manson's path I'm like
what tough yeah yeah Paul Mantz was you
told me and I was very super 5:00 to
5:15 my mom sighs mom so so he know he
had committed one crime himself with a
gun but he didn't and he would hold a
knife just don't put his dick in you but
he did some cases he would he would rape
man yeah yeah I've point yeah you do
that but that would real ladies man real
ladies man and but he'd bring all these
Hollywood parties but people stop
sleeping with his gals his stable
because they would give everyone
chlamydia really yeah pass that around
Hollywood is that right yeah he had a
theater station Sunday his favorite was
a 14 year old Wow you know some tough
guys and then you know what else is he
never actually told anyone to kill
anyone no no they have they know they
almost don't for a fact he never said go
kill that person go do this his thing
was is if if someone thinks it's their
idea they're more willing to go through
with the plan
Wow so he would he plant a seed you just
go lead you to a plant I said a lot of
it his followers are evils [ __ ] you know
he gets all the blame don't you around
he's evil as balls but his followers
were evil too because they were
impressed was gone I Eve young but they
were young lots of acid LSD but also
when when they decided to commit the
murders it was before Charlie Jiki was
gone then came home that like man we we
should do this and then that's when he
was like well this is how I you know and
would lead him yeah I have a horse to
water and they would do it Wow Wow crazy
girls man
Zero's and then the thing up the girls
you don't have the Manson girls know
what the thing that the thing that I
just thinking of crazy
he's got along Charles Manson and
there's another kind of dead may appear
as holy [ __ ] how was it what you guys do
you guys get here on your bikes music
it's like straight-up biker gang like
riding bikes in LA there's no rules
there's no whole bars you just go you
want fast you want in and out of cars
yeah
[ __ ] unbelievable dress bro it is
welcome I say now with your car if
you're in a car your [ __ ] if you're on a
motorcycle you just you do whatever you
want if you want you hit someone's
window with your [ __ ] Jeep on kids
keep going give them a little sorry
bunch of wave and keep going
sorry I'm Donald Cerrone the scary stuff
is though when they don't see you yeah
that's the bra your boy Juan has maybe
got the worst years I've ever seen on a
human being I mean in other words just
they look very very wet those are the
worst yeah that maybe this one looks
like it poorly knee his just look like I
mean there's just enclosed but this it
he's on Hajj is like real hard work job
which is like rubbing it you know trying
to get out go home and do it he wanted
he wanted to have one of it he wanted a
tough guy Oh take a loan look in pliers
and hear your ears have held up pretty
much I mean not really he's got he's got
cars a bit of it yeah yeah well do you
have to get initiated in for one of
those uh being met patches yeah man he's
got to be [ __ ] pretty cool if he
crazy huh oh my new tattoo he would wear
that doing that non [ __ ] stuff from
kitten so do you see we parked the bus
just right there on on sunset
I love it we're selling the side of the
road you guys I'm driving I get it I got
a taxi at a picture here we are just a
picture of him on the foot on Sunset
Boulevard in this world RV so we come
down because I'm doing this ADR for this
movie yesterday we explained
so it's uh we got a what I don't know
that so the ADR is looping so you go in
so sometimes when you're shooting
outside your voice doesn't come through
this together
sound closely you've got to go back
we're like not sure your name is mumbled
and it got really so you already shot it
and now you're coming back doing the
voice yeah and they'll run the scene on
a TV you got a little mic in your ear
thing on your ear and it's like has
three beeps now on the four imaginary
beep you say the line you try to match
your lips and try and sync it up and
suck so yeah quite tough takes it's not
yes sounds like you'd be difficult yeah
and you have to reenact the moment you
were in right so if you're crying and
you're angry you're excited like whoa
but just standing there yeah and you
like you dig it cowboy are they acting
these a lot of fun now I'm eating it up
yeah yeah and working a lot right yeah
I'm on equalizer too right now Denzel
Washington out in Boston I'm not ever
seven weeks out there your co-star with
Denzel Washington that's [ __ ] amazing
it's cool and who you playing little
scumbag guy who I can't really get in
cells brother when it's just an awful
movie I mean when you're at the beauty
by like cow well it's it's you know it's
the equalizer there's no there's not
really nobody carries no just kills
everyone everybody and have you seen
them on another family fashioned yeah
right have you seen them or yeah we have
obviously no we I mean all the fight
scenes and stuff earth all right there
that's cool man yeah I mean with Brand X
stunts so we do a lot of the core
graphing the fights and doubling the
guys and it's fun man I enjoy I really
enjoy it do you have your own stunt man
no I am my own stunts they don't weigh
my info but they don't want you to get
anybody you tell call Charlie amen
you're gonna take a fall in the back man
bring in the Dom Cerrone this a guy's
done man he knows his [ __ ] so like we
had Eddie the scene where mmm the
building explodes boom eagle blowing out
the back and I was like you're gonna put
me on a line set me on fire ripped me
out I'd do that for free on a Tuesday
afternoon
oh really yeah so I was doing a
commercial this mini-cooper commercial
and I had to do my own fight stunts but
of course me I'm an actor so but uh
please I'm just moves I see you have
done it you know you see me me now bro
he was like a vandal
he's very ballerina yep good-looking he
watch me here you compare the juggler he
wants for any guy go how they do he goes
you're doing everything wrong and then
he gave me a lesson for me
hey like literally goes you actually
taught me some [ __ ] though well I didn't
want to step on your coach oh yeah you
know so I had to be you're doing it
wrong come to come talk to me over here
on the corner it's great you go check
them but but i but a lot of that work so
I'm back I'm back is the plan to forget
the Octagon no I'm not kidding you
Denzel Washington yeah but you know I'm
out here doing this movie puppy love it
should be out a couple months or right
they're like finishing all the color
editing everything then that was a movie
I shot up in Canada was about man two
and a half months I was up there so fun
loved it and I secretly want you never
to fight again because you're already
proved everything aren't you're the most
what was he like the second most
winningest [ __ ] yeah well bonuses uh
most ones about visiting just this last
fight ahead just took the lead on the
most fights over I'm now in second place
okay that's pretty [ __ ] amazing
now having said all that all we want is
you to stay healthy and become an actor
that's what I that's what I go I can't
should be the next Tom Hardy yeah yeah
these are my buddies Noah and camps oh
sweet can you bring calm down man iced
recited by as part of the club with the
biker gangs though they are out crew we
brought the trailer with all the
Harley's around around super day how
long you here we're driving to Oakland
we're gonna do a bunch of media I'm like
pictures of stuff for the movie so the
whole cast rented my RV and they're
jumping in we're driving to Oakland this
afternoon damn that's cool yes refund so
but with you in regards to the UFC
Hollywood can kick rocks you just want
to keep fighting well no no I'm
definitely moving that way but I'm
absolutely fighting I love it five more
years imma fight come on god damn it you
take this over no he's fighting five
words can you give it maybe another year
two years alone you have nothing to
prove right down but I love it I love I
love love love it
he loves fire you do though yeah well
you know I mean if you love doing and
love doing it so why would I just throw
it away but it Roger in retrospect the
Dare until fight which I thought you
would have still took it yeah of course
you don't give a [ __ ] about the win you
must [ __ ] about now I mean it's about
mattering no no man I mean he showed up
perfectly execute a plan man whipped my
ass you know that's what happens his
name of this game I heard a birdie told
me that when he stepped into the Octagon
he weighed two hundred and one piece big
boy there's a big boy he was a bit he's
a monster yeah he hit really hard I was
like oh god I'm crying my nose sued
again as I was thinking not in the face
not in the face um but hey I got no
excuses matter what I do I love it I've
been on both sides of the of the win and
loss right you've been on more wins than
losses that's a little cowboy but damn
right
the only thing with that with that
couple you know this better than anyone
is while you're doing movies and
traveling your boys in RVs guys like
deer until you're in the training room
yeah you know I'm saying sure yeah yeah
stay out keep want to keep acting keep
betting you got such a great person out
there that I just want to see you become
a [ __ ] Desmond I want to see you cry
oh I'll sing together yeah Donald was so
emotion is not even about the money free
Donald it's more about the thrill hey
real quick we've been on movie set but I
love the money I mean let's not get
carried away
no no you're not doing for peanuts but
but acting is not a thrill it's like
hurry up and wait game to that but I do
a lot of the stunt stuff so that's
there's a lot of thrill that keeps you
going yeah I mean like something like
the movie godless we did that they just
came out of Netflix super plug right
there bang watch the star people Yankee
Jardine main well Keith and yeah I mean
taking those horse falls and all that
it's crazy you know it's fun you spend
time with Jordan all the time he walked
me he walked me down and we were at an
airport I came out where you guys come
with me I go I guess so soft space and
giant there's an amazing coffee place
copyboy
yeah and the guys about to close down he
goes hold on is there any way do you
think there's any way you could keep it
open just pours one of the Sumatra what
yeah he's the nice and he and I sat
there and tasted coffee slowly as he
broke down the tasting notes of it he's
doing he's doing good right dog yeah he
is he's he
I think he's found his his own in that
call he's really trying he loves it
loves it but I'm there five years five
years come on all right so five years
one fight a year we talking three well
I'm going back to five just guys going
back to 5555 you're doing the cut
against that gonna be hard to slow well
I it was but I'm only 175 175 every day
so it's like you're fine
I'm fine just I'm more focused I can't
at 70 I can just not train [ __ ] off I'm
get away with more into it at 55 right
so let's do it man let's go back um or
[ __ ] yeah I probably won't take 20 a
year anymore I'm probably take it down a
little bit good you'll talk to me first
- I'll come in here well you just keep
the hype got me do one a year and they
do your movies and promote around that
cuz real really what you can just do
super fights sure I just do popular
fights what is it well now we're not
doing any fun we're not doing just any
fight man I'm a punch the [ __ ] out of
your manager boys he gets so bad you
guys to help him with when they when he
goes what about their until and [ __ ]
liver or where was it yeah a lot of mall
or some [ __ ] but you guys I can't do
that yeah god damn it cowboy we know
we'll fight anybody anytime it's why
people love him Darren tells like I have
enormous respect great yeah it's up to
it's up to [ __ ] coaches and they're
at his camp to protect a fighter against
himself we said this about my Cowboys
Cowboys should be a multi time world
champion yeah his skill set mindset but
he also likes kind of like again just to
give a [ __ ] that's Donald it's part of
what makes you awesome though it's just
so what else going on nothing talking
fighting good he doesn't even know
fighters are yeah I might and another
thing about this guy cuz no you're not
have like you never heard of him but
they took the other tier until he's the
guy that's getting it wasn't just
respect to him I just honestly had no
idea but you know I do I bow that I have
a very clear understanding who Darren
[ __ ] till is now yeah yeah sure come
on high level
no I know I love all [ __ ] yeah
um we've been just being silly geese is
what we're doing and and so you guys be
the geese I'll be the gander no problem
but you you're not still doing the
podcast right well I just I'm so bad at
life you know I just can't you're not
bad at life you bet it's taking a
regimen doing podcast my dad but that
con is it man the kids getting spring
break office makeup let's take a dive
trip because I'm really in a diagnostic
dad March I can't even plan next weekend
let alone I can't there's nothing worth
long as what are you doing February 7th
late I can affect anyone doing next
third I said between who knows and I'm
gonna take a fight to who knows if I get
them a movie you know how the acting is
yeah wouldn't you so that's the hardest
day in the world with the audition taste
me I don't know how people get through
that because that is so so do you where
audition all the time now yeah I get
them all here you work with your voice
yeah so what I mean it's just so we try
to get like the good thing is a lot of
the roles that I get are like shoot them
up kind of tough guy idea so out with
the Denzel thing car D in that scene or
I'd already have like the outfit on
because right now if we had to do a
story about us being Indians or
something it would be hard to get into
character right so that's the hardest
part for me like but if you're already
in if all of us are sitting here you
know bosz narrows and we got the outfit
on it's a little easier to portray that
right you can look what'd I tell you
about playing a tough guy because what
they'll try to dan that's how I got a
row I did that I didn't i sat down and
did that I didn't get yellow screen I'll
just call me because real tough guy I'll
show you that I say that I wish I want
to see it cuz guys like you yeah what
they'll try to do is you'll be under the
impression let's get da Cerrone and they
gotta be a tough guy but you know why
you know why Hollywood Hollywood does
that because there's no real tough guys
right so when they go be a tough guy
same you have guys like thinking what a
tough guy would do yes I've got real
tough guys like you you don't even have
to raise your voice you could smile
through the whole thing that's I just
kind of take your time so you're playing
you almost play an exaggerated version
of yourself Cal that's what yeah not
even an exaggerated version just
everything is real cash because violence
for you is is essentially your heart
rate is the same as when you're sitting
down yeah right yeah
I would never let them do anything it's
all because the people who build city do
weird [ __ ] is it you know like tough
guys are scary if they're just if the
end of just picking their boots or they
tell you everything they're talking
about writing telling the guy I just
need you yeah yeah yeah leave it open
for another five and then I see this
blue eyes yes yeah yeah super creepy
he's got no shoulders nice guy a sipping
coffee while telling me about the
tasting notes you know which is very
eerie with it with a very scary guy
who's who's actually got really refined
taste I want to get to you in a second
but we're gonna talk so what's like Dana
you are but take Fletcher to when he's
talking about something serious take
just cut his beard off flick it [ __ ]
come on come on look I gotta sigh had to
shave why is he dude I have no idea and
I I texted my smells like beard butter
which is attractive whoa oh you talked
to me that I could smell like the his
beard nothing lot bad smells he sent me
this picture I like him without a beard
he looks good without a beard really one
have you seen I would say I would say
the comment but back in the day he
didn't have a beard when I first met him
I am look at that he looks good without
a beard dude I like him more I said
there I said it
wow he's a handsome dude man it's crazy
right
sings of patron cow he goes holy [ __ ]
the other you know I count on your voice
you guys can take your boy just got
through chemo that was his thing like
the beard was this thing yeah but I just
got it he played like a great like you
you know using that Recaro when he's
like that bad you know he's always
playing that bad he's in equalizer
mm anyways that beard he always sticks
out on the accountant right yeah the big
fish yeah yeah there you go
I remember that damn butt so what's
going on oh nothing like Kate's beard no
I'm still boxing on a high level yeah
yeah you come back and you see some [ __ ]
I'm excited so I'm super excited for you
blowing us off for dinner I could not
have you know is his wife's birthday I
tried you guys go to try something out
she goes where are you going I got
nowhere well so
we had big plans we had chick-fil-a for
dinner you did 12 burgers we got twelve
and three fries twelve chicken salad are
you here tonight
no we're headed Oakland we went over
this already my bros enduring they
attention please play attempt it so
here's the problem we're driving in
which LA is no place to pull an 80 foot
trailer and bad I do know that though so
something's happening with my RV beep
beep [ __ ] sirens going off we're
pushing it you can't drive 90 miles an
hour just the gas pedal goes all by the
floor but they don't recommend you just
keep it there right so that's how I
Drive it and so of course we [ __ ] the
engine up somehow on our way here and so
what we're having this problem now we
got to go to the studio because the
studio told us that we can park there
that's where and I said I'm not driving
in LA out of state somewhere else and
rode the bikes in not only got a spot
for you so Colton
the guy's directing us you know how you
getting those studios are tight yeah oh
yeah so of course we take out a couple
things couple things got a brand-new
trailer kinda smashed oh we have in each
side of the building no I mean oh I just
swing the guy's dragna's it I take a
left tray that you know when you turn
hard yeah box out so it caught this how
about the trailer is there a lunch tub
I mean buff out then did all you guys
jump out and like alright well then we
had like Dario's it took it took
literally probably three hours to like
forward back I felt like I was Austin
Powers turning the [ __ ] golf did
exactly percent but eighty feet with the
trailer so I got a turn left to back it
up right you know and then fix it cause
it was holding with all this movie stuff
everything about moving to LA cowboy
so now [ __ ] know so then we torture that
would do the thing and then they're like
yeah you guys can't stay here I said so
what the [ __ ] was that about why do we
what they told you you couldn't stay
there and then he says I need your
insurance information so we can nod am
bill you day I met my wedding I had
friends like this at my wedding we were
at the Ojai Valley in the spa really
nice [ __ ] beautiful place and I got a
lot of degenerate friends you understand
so all of a sudden the wedding planner
comes running out she goes there's a
problem I go and she's your huge friend
is about to fight the security guards
and so I go why so I go running out into
the parking lot and my friends who don't
have a lot of money one of them very big
guy uh-oh my buddy Frank you don't know
him but Frank Martin who's has a
unfortunately now a brain tumor that's
about um but he's a hothead and a great
guy but but he and my other buddy Johnny
and Steve shocker decided you know what
we're gonna drive a lot of huge RV into
the parking lot of this very exclusive
spa rebel and no we're gonna stay there
but oh by the way we're also gonna we're
also gonna pull out an umbrella and
we're gonna fry up some fun dogs on our
hibachi What's Wrong are you hit potty
what's wrong I go [ __ ] Frank and him art
that this huge security guard Frank is
six seven and they're bumping chests
while there's blubbers [ __ ] am I
reading I go on my friend get you
[ __ ] RV get into [ __ ] on what planet
do you think this is all right I know
cooking cooking burgers why not cook
your own burger when you this wedding
food or resorts that guys like you can't
do this my baby yes we do maybe he yeah
cooks a six-star burger I agree with he
probably does
Oh hides me tough it's tough it's my
wedding stuff Oh some people like me I
love my rvs my bed my toothbrush my
clothes are hanging out how the packet
it should go just pick up and go
anywhere yes they kicks out and now
we're parked on the side of you have a
shower and everything in the show yeah
of course
looks like you know legit RV what's that
thing get it almost cost to fulfill that
[ __ ] giant truck bus hmm about $800
hold on I don't know Harvey did I get
you I don't know [ __ ] about our VA guy
he's got a giant box yeah it's a bus
it's about something like that cause
I'll quarter million dollars yeah about
a quarter million take a look when I
pull my boat and we yeah he's gonna give
a picture of it those are my old ones
let's see if there's ceramic oh yeah so
much gum so you can see that's it right
there if you go back here with our dog
middle down down down that's my old one
no right in the middle the bikes parked
next to it right next to me running see
me neck down to the right yep that's it
done really sure bro that those are like
the giant buses the UFC does that's
right there it is with my house rock
star click on the far right went to the
rolling apartment man yeah we love it
run picture [ __ ] face right now why
you so bad I mean it's the worst it's
your honor he's not good at being bad at
basketball
that's me back in the bad [ __ ]
into the bow-wow whoo and you got a boat
yeah well course he has a boat but hold
on till you were just like I'm gonna buy
my own bus man up oh you see we started
we started you know with a few and then
we went up a few and now we're driving
there's levels to this bus there's
levels to again your every year you know
that's why I'm sorry
look at you with brilliant look at the
size of Blake row my god I can't see
anything in front of the chalet that's
better
there it is that's a picture you sent me
there it is that's a Chateau Marmont oh
my god I can't believe it's not along
there no yes nice we get a little ticket
a parking violation well they just give
you the 3 bucks a night yeah bunch of
parking you showing your toes hanging
hanging a banging yeah that's incredible
but man spot that bad boy do they how
about two years ago Oh Danny not for a
while yeah it's my fifth one just low
like I said we're slowly every year you
got to keep getting better right we
can't go back I want to keep fighting to
keep paying keep spending all your money
is already spent all your money well if
I spend all my money in taxes then I
have to oh I pay my taxes every time if
you spend all your money you have to
work harder to get it like he's
humongous and be a basketball player
wow he's stalling cowboy crazy anyways
these physically like oh wow NBA
all-star beast we're sure like very very
strong mmm yeah but yeah but you could
get the point where movies would take
care of those payments
I love it really hitting that yeah of
course I got to do something when I'm
done what am i doing I'm done fighting
you're gonna be an actor oak be an actor
yeah I'm working on it I'm how stand up
going it's good man let's hear a little
bit come on don't be the worst thing
ever do some jokes bro why some jokes do
it now funny but that was a banker you
like do some jokes I was like oh okay do
some banking you can depend on golf you
guys have it chambered see shooter ready
to go stories brother no you're like
this is what sells then they'll have to
hammer them out that doesn't work that's
like saying throw some light cakes yeah
I'd [ __ ] kick right now yeah I'll
shared four it's better let's kill em no
problem okay I got a joke all right
this was the this is how you weren't it
wasn't directed toward you but you can
you can step in I've never I've never I
don't tell jokes when my stand-up is you
know but this is a joke that I don't
know anyone who does but you all right
ready all right let's see if you guys
dare you guys not to laugh at this corny
joke ready do you guys hear about the
worst magician in the world he's like
all right he gets up and he he basically
says I realize nothin I am now going to
have the strongest man in the audience
come up here with this baseball bat
right here dude got this baseball bat
let me show you guys how this works Gang
Gang starts hitting solid binds pass it
around you can tell it's a solid pine
baseball bat this gentleman right here
kind of huge guy comes up he goes what's
your name sir he goes Burton he goes
what are you doing goes
pig farmer knows how much you weigh 300
pounds yes Wow big man you gonna say
he's strongest strongest guy in my
County all right so we prove these the
strongest guy here you go here's this
baseball bat wait take this baseball bat
I want you to hit me in the head as hard
as you can with this baseball bat it's a
long joke so Bert's like Bert's like hey
shut the [ __ ] up bro and Bert's like
yeah but if I hit you in the head I'll
smash your head and kill you because
they said to me I'm a magician
just take the bat hit me in the head
it's already can it goes I know but if I
hit you this is a real bat I'm gonna
literally take your dogs out for the
last time I want you
take the bat hit me on the side of the
head as hard as you can
so Bert goes all right you asked for it
fine all the crowd he just takes and
hits him as hard as he can across a head
blood goes everywhere he [ __ ] gets
knocked out they got a rush to another
hospital swelling on the brain
[ __ ] he's in a coma for four months
they got a drain fluid he's almost dead
he finally four months later he comes
out of it and as he comes out of it he
goes tada
don't ever tell that one how did you
guys not laugh at that hotel / this guy
I was looking at he knows because I dare
tonight he's gonna murder hey boo you
out of the Comedy Store for that all
right one more joke no it's very good
he's gone on our boat docking quick hold
on yeah obviously a really good one I
dare you not to laugh on this one ready
what did the snail say when it was
riding on the turtle's back see got him
ah that's a good joke you got me okay
cuz get it the snail isn't used to going
that fast sure [ __ ] off man you guys you
know you don't know those good you're
enjoying it yeah it's great man yeah
killing it yeah it's going well all
right oh well brother this is scary ah
different scarier than fighting for sure
but it'd be like like going into fight
if you know exactly what moves that guy
was gonna do like you're not gonna be a
scared like you should know your [ __ ]
you should know your set yeah you [ __ ]
up it's on you if you're putting in the
work and then I'll get my reps like my
training at the Comedy Store my grout
like I have a big show tonight
you do yeah where Ontario Oh see you out
here right now what time should I leave
fun too oh that's the worst traffic you
you I'm not kidding when you drive from
LA to Ontario you sometimes get from
here to Seattle faster I'm asking me a
piece do you want to jump in the bus not
a bad idea take you two out take you two
hours two hours you get to drop you off
traffic is bad it's not practice you can
practice them along the way do it for
you guys for I do it for us you know
hopefully now I got to March I have 36
shows come on
solo now you're running solo oh yeah
I'll break a hundred I've done 100 shows
once I cut once I'm in Buffalo I'll have
it be 100 shows yeah when did you when
did you get to a point where you were
walking into the Octagon which is
impossible situation saying not be
nervous where you were you know nervous
you're always nervous but when did you
get to a point where that where you were
able to benefit from the energy where it
wasn't oh never never never really still
this is like it's oh it's crazy man I
love you I that's the feeling that you
chase that's why I go skydiving and ride
my Harley 100 miles an hour because it's
not feeling it you can't touch it yeah
and you know there's nothing you've ever
done other than walking octagon that
gives you that feeling man especially
they raise your hand front of millions
of people it's imagine standing on stage
and having people screaming your name
but in the beginning it's got to be like
so overwhelming it's all you can think
about and then after a while you use it
right you can turn it into energy sure
when did that happen it's always is it
always precarious it's always always
yeah always always
yeah I think that's I think that's why
you know with like soldiers just PTSD
off see some have real PSD and then with
athletes you know when there's
depression there's the blaming on CT a
lot of it is they go from being this
complete badass from whether it's
military or fighting a juice or the
juice and getting all this attention to
just screeching halt BAM just be a
regular civilian society go that's right
and they're like [ __ ] man like go it's
CT your brain trance command no I'm just
depressed as [ __ ] and I want to go the
other way I just want to be a regular
civilian of these drop off over there
and let me [ __ ] go yeah
yeah here's a couple guns his um
infiltrate that building and just do
whatever you got to do yeah
good luck you do not want to be a
regular civilian cowboy because you feel
crazy because you can't find that juice
you're gonna go crazy most societies
traditionally always had a like when you
came back from war soldiers were done
most societies traditionally had sort of
a like a humane process to get you back
inside you can't just drop a young man
who's been in that intense and
experienced that's where you have
problems because you have nowhere to
place that energy sure but it's athletes
- yes and I'm not comparing them I'll
see what military does complete opposite
both athletes they get dunce like well
he played in NFL for six years all right
now go be a regular dude like [ __ ] man
ought to do money your goods like die
gas with no rat lived a pretty lavish
lifestyle man no one taught me to you
know how to invest my money and stuff an
ounce was just beyond it and figure my
[ __ ] out yep go do it
yep so you're almost incarcerated you
you're in some tough times we're all
slave to the juice
we're all a [ __ ] slave to it I mean I
really believe that no not everyone what
I have to taste the juice if you're if
you're a comic if you're lucky the idea
of not doing stand-up the idea of not
doing what are you talking to a
professional thud into input so we've
all tasted the juice yes my mom's not
chasing the jitter I'm saying I'm saying
once you have tasted it yeah it's really
or maybe it's a personality that's drawn
to it in the first place because when I
was younger I couldn't imagine doing the
juicer we did something here because you
know the adrenaline oh yeah like I could
never go like if you don't taste the
nectar of a sweet woman ever you've no
idea you have no idea be a month once
you taste that juice you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah chasing us they gotta go do it I
need more I want Jason yeah I want the
plum juicy one yeah we get Harvey
Weinstein tasted the juice of those
sweet celebrities and just went nuts
yeah Buddhists teach you to get rid of
that sensation changing that sensation
they just lock themself high in the
mountains where there's nothing around
they're just unrealistic get the [ __ ] on
high that's probably true should you
some current events let's do some
current event time you guys have to get
out yeah we don't have care we're here
all day everything we're here on the
podcast all day with you I do it all day
count yeah we've only done for this week
yeah it's Oh God really
yeah all right the first one as you know
Matt Lauer has been fired for sexual
harassment
with like eight victims not a basic
eight eight victim said victims
well I guess there are sexual harassment
victims but uh yeah there's also footage
of him
say bye please play it and curry there's
footage of what him saying bye to anchor
let me watch one guy goes I want to see
if there's any hypocrisy here real quick
you made 25 million a year to cowboy
Oh dodged it kind of you know I might
might what I think about all the time is
when journalists start becoming
celebrities and journalists are their
own personality and their presence
becomes more important than the actual
objective news they're supposed to be
giving and that never feels like it's
the good thing I think out loud was a
beast those again it was very good at
what he did right I mean yeah megyn
kelly she's getting good but yeah she's
gotten but they're good at what they do
yeah I know the best that's why they're
yeah well the reason though the reason
you make $25,000,000 ears because you
have credibility so if comes out of Matt
Lauer's mouth people assume it's true
that that's very very that's a very
valuable commodity when people trust
what you're saying be the draw that's
why yeah yeah the number-one ratings
anymore let us get chin all right a
teacher in Indiana was a cot snorting
coke yeah and her students is the one
that snitched on her dry sneeze all show
her out a little bit of the footage she
wanted you to gave him a bump it have
been good right yeah just give me an a
and I won't say [ __ ] were these kids
thinking you can see her she locked the
classroom door and then she's kind of
like doing lines she's just organizing
the lines right now no one could see her
on their lunch break this is the four
o'clock a little devil's dandruff on her
leg not a good idea
God the the new era of phones just
kitschy but she's not even trying that
hard to hide herself no she don't think
anyone's around
she's probably she just needs it if I
was back there I wouldn't have snitch I
would own up like hey listen Nathan
table thief snorting coke did I break
I'm gonna mean am I never showing up
otherwise I'm releasing this thing on my
Instagram but that was her uh-huh that's
her 2042 yep twenty four bump in line
must have a real problem or just tired
ish but she says she had she felt sick
so she needed to get it normally she'll
get it after school she'd get her drug
dealer to come after school but she was
feeling so sick that she needed it that
I guess she's having withdrawals yeah
you know oh you feel bad for a little
bit feel bad for a dead damn well you
know anybody who has a cocaine addiction
that you know anybody who has an
addiction is probably caught up in it so
how old is I'm worthy of something let
me see the picture again that's a bummer
yeah yeah rockin a meth might be meth
well she had a bunch of drug
paraphernalia in a car they found other
stuff quite a pile well she likes to
party
drug addict did you ever have any
teachers hit on you cowboy no I have me
neither I wish to god I guess right
never never
Alwine were bueno never saying that they
would come to you and say didn't miss
Thompson uh molest you as well and I'd
be like know who I wish yeah I would
just be like no I'm it's something
[ __ ] over the last year but molest me
never yeah she even ate my ass I don't
all this stuff all the teachers are like
where were they when I was around I
think I think it's it's it's just you
hear about it you know of all the aliens
in there he's gonna hear about it but I
never had like a super attractive
teacher that me neither my girl even
this lady just you know this one's down
lines a coke give her a little [ __ ] teen
I got a theory on all of this though I
got a I got a theory on this and before
you read this like I think and this can
be this can be my driving knowledge well
so like we're hearing all about sex and
drugs and like now there's no privacy
right everybody's got a camera yeah and
so what are what the biggest back before
cameras and stuff what kept people
essentially in line was in a lot of ways
religion was the idea of morality was
the idea that church yet you know and we
were primarily a Christian nation so if
you look at the 50s and and it started
changed in the 60s but man you kept in
line because there was a moral code no I
think they were I think you're wrong I
think they were doing it there's just
weren't cameras for TV attachable a hard
position Michael Jordan was the biggest
dirt bag in the game there were no cam
that's very to say Babe Ruth was the big
tag in the game Mickey Mantle passed all
sorts of [ __ ] yes but there's no there's
no there's no question there was a
sexual revolution that came about in the
60s and 70s for sure but people
or that in this country there was a
puritanical mindset I'm not saying she
didn't go on behind closed doors but
definitely what it was way more
conservative because one of the things
that keep people in line was this notion
of sort of public morality public
standards so when you watch people on TV
they always call the 50s the humorless
generation cuz you didn't even make
[ __ ] sexual jokes man it was very
Elvis Presley he was taken off the air
because you didn't shoot it below those
and now I think the new religion sort of
the new thing that's gonna keep people
in that's killed that sexual revolution
a lot of ways is shame is this idea you
better be [ __ ] careful because if you
get you can get publicly shamed now and
it can be one video it can be two
accusations so I predict that you're
going to see the rebirth of a very
different very conservative culture
that's gonna come out of all this in a
lot of ways it may pass but I don't
think so I think healthy people are
conservative I think they get smarter I
think this has always been going on it's
just brought to light a well here that's
a good point so so the second part I was
gonna say I don't think shame changes
behavior
shame suppress his behavior shame will
push it underground but it ain't gonna
change anybody but believe me shame is a
powerful powerful thing to keep people
in line it feels a reasonably man women
have always been the ones who had to
deal with shame right always the scarlet
letters written about this in
puritanical societies you'd never want
to be called a [ __ ] you never want to be
looked at as somebody who slept with a
lot of guys I believe now this new
public shaming is going to do the same
thing to men now your biggest fear is
that you're considered your outer
there's a dirt bag out it as a womanizer
I don't as somebody who takes liberties
with women no I see I think you'll be
outed if you're a creep if you're a bad
dude I think if you're just a ladies man
a guy who gets a lot of chicks you're
fine okay but hold on if you're a ladies
man in the workplace so in other words
you're you know you got you have people
that work for you you find a woman
attractive might make a sexual advance
you might drop something you might even
say something that's kind of sexual that
makes her feel uncomfortable you're not
aware of your own impact sometimes you
know you're doing your thing I'm just
telling you that what's going to happen
is people are going to be very aware of
that - yeah I think I think it's just a
phase I think they'll be conserved in
the office space I think it's a phase
and I think guys who are worried about
it say stuff like that I'm not saying
you should be worried but I'm saying
guys who were who were act
creeps are the ones concerned about it
the regular dudes not concerned if I'm
not so concerned about what I'm making
I'm not saying you answer I see what
you're saying yeah everyone's gonna
watch our P's and Q's yeah that's a
little bit yeah but it's in your DNA I'm
saying yes those creeps screw so what I
baa the creeps other ones yeah it's on
and you're a lion or you're not yes but
here's the thing I think it's gonna push
like there's gonna be a whole
underground of like anytime a society
like Germany or whatever is really
conservative
there's a [ __ ] underground that gets
deeply perverted because that [ __ ] that
Energy's got to go somewhere and it's
gonna happen it's gonna be really
interesting to see what happens it's a
it's we're witnessing a cultural like a
cultural tidal wave right now this is
very interesting and and but like you
said the air of like the religion that
held yes years for years for years and
now this this new generation is kind of
this is the new religion yeah this is
this is your can't get away starting to
figure out that just like Santa Claus
God has not really yeah you can't get
away people get more knowledgeable yeah
Mayans man they they would just say oh
the moon god and the wind God and and
then through modern science like now you
know the moon comes every night because
science proves it the winds there's no
wind god there's no rain God as now you
know so all the gods they start they
start dwindling because we start
figuring out how that becomes you know
and now it's it's like I need overall I
think overall it's gonna end up being
kind of a good thing
because for the first knowledge isn't
raining it's like taking the highest
bidder like oh now all of a sudden
homosexuality is okay and the in
religion like here's the take the new
card it's gonna rewrite the Bible again
for the 27 well that's because the new
religion is liberalism and and self like
so self-governance like your own
self-expression it has become tan-tan
amounts it's the it's actually stands on
top of the pyramid so anytime you ever
tell somebody who's I'm well I feel
transgender or I or I'm gay whatever it
might be or this is Who I am
if you can test that and if you use
religion or whatever it is another moral
sort of belief systems are always it
rather than me no I'm not no no no I'm
I'm a libertarian
I believe maximum personal freedom but I
believe essentially a full-blooded true
Republican I believe in Constitution I'm
not I'm not a big government guy right I
don't believe in big government I think
it's dangerous so I think big government
is two things coercive they passed laws
they pass taxes and you better be very
careful of mob rule you better be very
careful of because because you know
history shows us that the bigger
government gets the more oppressive our
regime I'm a libertarian bro I mean for
the most part I'm Way more right-wing in
that sense but I'm socially liberal I'm
socially liberal well who's gonna
monitor my man Trump's drunk tweets that
he does that's a problem
it is not surprising all this for me he
gets on he puts his presidential hat on
and does everything else then he goes
home has a box of wine for sure he
drinks box wine he never drinks he's not
drinking right and gets on Twitter and
just starts going nuts
god damn he's like roasting people you
know and who would say another
[ __ ] thing about my hair I'll
bomb their whole [ __ ] country don't
tweet it like okay a lot of one no one
has a smooth process like actually let
us see your phone sir [ __ ] a lot of a
lot of pundits and people think about
this stuff have said that this whole
sexual harassment movement started with
that [ __ ] guy he was the best of the
worst that we could pick for sure
Hillary Clinton is terrible person
terrible her husband was a sex criminal
according to I mean a lot of yeah I mean
they're over here you know your
Democratic Party needs is ally up he was
running cigar blunts and girls [ __ ]
[ __ ] so let's I got my own problems in
the Democratic Party there's no [ __ ]
doubt about that I think yeah I don't
like you know they have the answers to
the a lot of the problems but I'm just
saying it's it this is important to talk
about just the murders that they're
aligned with man is crazy you know I
mean I don't know it's just yeah Oh what
else you got let's move on before cowie
gets himself yes
Laguna Beach woman dropped off her like
over $300,000 Ferrari to get it serviced
and a dude slapped on a jacket a Ferrari
jacket and found keys next to the
passenger side of one of the Ferraris
and just took it yeah so I was missing
for like 20 27 hours before they even
knew he was gone he brought it back so
he was back because he got caught at a
gas station
weeks later begging for gas money for
the Ferrari and yeah so it came back
without a scratch on it this is all good
yeah so missing power sufism vomit caked
on the side damn dude
yes sir looks stable heat up oh I don't
think you must better mugshot what bugs
me it's got a great haircut
that's an expensive haircut run get the
[ __ ] have in your face you take a lot of
time with a hair Pam his mug
yeah they I mean God God love him though
I mean hey if you go people are your
Lamborghini next to cowboy why he beat
up though he's a he's a drug addict he's
that's probably just swords and stuff
price there's vomit inside the the
Lamborghini it was damage though I don't
know what great here you're talking
about is we've seen here line like you
he trusted me here I this here's walk
you come on that's a foot look at words
I would say that's great here bro that's
good here I'll take that hair all day
you [ __ ] you you see you yeah what so I
won't take that her pee on his lip
though I if I could have that hair I'll
take a herpe on no you would not all
right I'm being sued you got chipped
teeth look at you I do you fight what
else you got Jim well so the insurance
money she got from him she bought a
Lamborghini Huracan yeah so she's all
set worked out for both parties all
right so this has been going around a
lot of people are thinking it's fake but
it's actually real people
it looks like he's levitating but you
guys be the judge of this who's
levitating this football player I'll
have the actual video here so when he
catches the ball oh when he slides he
gets back up in a certain way that looks
like a levitation yeah Michael Jackson
does that exact move look how hard he
pushes off Freddie and Boop there it is
the cleats and just is like quad yeah
she's getting up doing moon walks I
don't know dude that looks very that
looks like Holy Ghost power
hey watch he gets up bleep come on man
you don't need to he did a little up
push look um scoot first the film man
looks like somebody pushed me while I
watched dancing
you know what that's rewind that's looks
like a over man the camera man look at
them Israel hold on that good thinking
hold on hold on
the keep bite eat [ __ ] for no reason
apparently slides in Bush no impress the
cameraman moves back the camera the
camera man did not yeah now that's that
that is yes fake so it's his underpants
are real everything on the watch the
watch the cameraman watch this
he's gonna move forward and move back
play it one more time while here's like
this watch him cameraman is there fall I
don't think it's that crazy
I don't either he's just getting up on a
you just says cleats toes some quad
strength I've been known to make that
same shield movement in the bedroom and
get back out of the football doesn't
movie that I think it's real I don't
think it's that crazy yeah it's not
great no I don't yeah but people are
flipping out about that really and
you're from you're from where and where
the US has never helped him out yes he
said don't you remember Don cook sounds
like oh I could the Brits fought their
ass off the Brits are bad my True Grit
True Grit the Brits how come you don't
wear cowboy boots bro not cowboy man
alright I don't mind them they live
those ones that I like cowboy boots and
those fences those you ever ridden a
horse yeah you you you you'll ride any
horse right can you get on anything
pretty much if you get there I can ride
it and if it's got a beat I can dance to
it is that right you can get on dance
yeah can dance really yeah I believe
that so you can get on it you can get on
a [ __ ] I like you wouldn't run a bowl
all right yeah of course you've wrote
Bulls before yeah it's the name cowboy
crazy it's fun and what about a horse
like a the stallion they say is really
dangerous to get on right know all the
stallion means it has his balls right
yeah so why would that make it any more
don't they fight other courses they take
off I don't know so one time one time I
was on I was on a mare which is a female
horse and she was in heat and I had a
stallion jump over the fence come up and
[ __ ] her while I was on it Wow bull the
hose wrap around me I'm like oh god I'm
stuck and he's you know rotated work is
a gangbang really knock it now my two
buddies are with me are in stitches
laughing there as of because he had
trapped both my arms I'm like holding on
to the thing and he's strong you're
lucky you didn't end up like mr. hands
yeah all did that last it felt like an
eternity but it's probably 27 do you
know the horses don't mess around they
get in there and they get out and they
get out and and they bump in my yeah and
my my riding for the day was done your
arm house oh I was traumatized yeah give
you an idea it was um I didn't even see
it coming I got bushwhacked I got side
side [ __ ] by stallion on is are easy
crazy the song hey do you still you used
train you still train with John Jones
right yeah I haven't seen him around so
if you have any idea what's going on
with that no nope no inside scoop no
idea I don't have an inside anything
yeah I know nothing yeah anything else
Jim got a few stuff you got more yeah
there's two more
all right man this is a little crazy so
a girl this is by the way this is from a
tabloid too but it's all over social
media some slim girl apparently had 50
surgeries to look like an Angelina Jolie
and this is what she looks like spot-on
she's got it nailed it nailed it
she's not well why are these dogs well
so something's worried about this girl
from the book of life and she does this
which is why there's obviously make up
to make it look scary or
Photoshop I know but why don't think
that's real switch I got her actual
Instagram why is the doctor
she has three hundred seventy seven
thousand followers a and then these are
some of the pictures so this disorder
normal but hey doctors you're dealing
with a crazy person why are you doing
this money suddenly it doesn't have
cheek piercings
I guess the pages got deleted oh wow
took her down poor thing might be fade
but see look she looks kind of normal
here you know
what's that she's no but she's truly
Chris she does makeup just looked crazy
yeah alright then in the middle what is
that she's not so poor thing she's a
mess oh my my my
not it's just it's just not well she's
not rolling everyone yes it sort of
movie magic yeah it's all [ __ ] yeah
but others everywhere see she kind of
looks normal
and one more you son sure all right
check this out that one that was just
for us to go and off that was pretty
much I saw this it's a company called
devil motors oh I need that so this is
actually gonna be in production well
this is the concept of it but there's
gonna be a production model coming out
and you can order it right now so 6x6
that the front shouldn't shown it to
cowboy know exactly why she Wow
the extremists look at that row Grogan's
the kind of guy he's like I'm eating a
pound of sauerkraut everyday like come
on that thing is sick you are a
rectangle in cash those like the right
they had dude look at that thing
450k yeah no problem or if it okay I got
a little winch in the back cuz you pull
do nothing is Brian Tesla one year to
deliver six C car thing no I thing is
sick yeah ah not for me I appreciate it
that yeah it'd be sick if cowboy got it
yeah rolling down something that bad
concept car though right
yeah but they're coming out with the
production so I look like the Bronco
what is
concepts it it comes out why what's a
watch it's too expensive to make to
mass-produce okay all right I got the
new Broncos it look like roundup the
Raptor rail why another do or a hat a
wrap you got rear after well I rolled it
after I had it 24 hours why why did I
roll it like what the [ __ ] how do you
roll a goddamn wrapped in what do you
see as he's really snowed and some high
Raptor was thought that engine was
signed by Jack Roush and so is my - it
was like a one-off a sick all camo and
then it snowed and it's supercharged and
I was like I bet I could get [ __ ]
wild and snow in my backyard and I did
that was in perfect control until I
rolled it and did it totaled it
oh yeah I did a couple but you're fine
yeah dude so that my Raptor you couldn't
even go faster than 10 miles now unless
you had your seatbelt on and when I
rolled the airbags my seat had air back
and I totally cocooned me in it like
when they wrap me up boom curtain I mean
it was what my [ __ ] were you doing on a
ranch we totaled a raptor give in her
god damn it I bet that thing was so sick
of so sick a little sad about roundel
cowboys roll rolled Raptor I want to see
just like the totals of Raptor man I
don't know if that really is on there
but it might be there it is upside down
it actually worked
booyah baby now what is the Raptor I'm
sorry this is a truck for dt4 it it's a
it's a badass ride it's a it's a badass
how much that cost to fix when you
definitely did that was unfixable yeah
that was 90 97 96 thousand I think it
was a sticker price on that drug 96
grand my insurance company was super
pumped that's crazy yeah it was it was I
had a less than 24-hours you miss it
though huh
yeah you don't really have it that long
as you say it's not drivable it's not
fixable knocked up - yeah
gone yeah broke them and if it's one of
one signed by ruched and yeah it's dance
good job what do you do yeah you get
another one
now we're talking about on here so we
got a little out of it there you go
rest in peace wrap to the second talk
about their brothers that's it your ID
drop knowledge damn Calvin you got to go
up north
yeah I'll you go south yeah we got six
hour drive to Oakland if you're in a
nice dress you're in San Francisco next
weekend I'm at Cobbs December 79 I'm
Monday I'm back to Boston alright star
come see me and next weekend at Cobbs
December 7 8 9 then 14 15 16 I'm in
Schaumburg improv in Schaumburg Chicago
December 13th Syracuse 14 through 16
Buffalo and then of course the big one
Boston Wilbur theater before UFC 220 I'm
at the Wilbur theater in Boston January
19th get tickets now deep at kake.com
for Brian and myself but we're also at
the Comedy Store
December 5th Brian and I are together
Los Angeles I'm kid live get tickets now
first one in a while
cowboy anything for we sign out dog no
man I might do this stand up with you
guys just come on yeah do it welcome
this is a fired kid with cowboy we're
out